- [Instructor] Which
slope field is generated
by the differential
equation the derivative of y
with respect to x is equal to x minus y?
And like always pause this video
and see if you can figure
it out on your own.
Well the easiest way to think
about a slope field, if I was, if i needed
to plot this slope field by hand,
I would sample a bunch of x and y points.
And then I would figure out what
the derivative would
have to be at that point.
And so what we can do
here, since we've already
drawn some candidate slope fields for us,
is figure out what we
think the slope field
should be at some points and see
which of these diagrams, these graphs,
or these slope fields actually show that.
So let's, let me make a little table here,
so I'm gonna have,
x, y and then the derivative
of y with respect to x.
And we can do it at a bunch of values,
so let's think about it.
Let's think about when, we're
at this point right over here.
When x is two and y is two.
When x is two and y is two, the derivative
of y with respect to x is
going to be two minus two.
It's going to be equal to zero.
And just with that, let's
see, here this slope
on this slope field does
not look like it's zero.
This looks like it's negative one.
So already I can rule this one out.
This slope right over looks
like it's positive one.
So I'll rule that out,
it's definitely not zero.
This slope also looks like positive one.
So I can rule that one out.
This slope at two comma two
actually does look like zero.
So I'm liking this one right over here.
This slope at two comma
two looks larger than one
so I can rule that out.
So it was that straight forward to deduce
that this choice right over here is,
if any of these are going to be
the accurate slope field, it's this one.
But just for kicks we could keep going
to verify that this is
indeed the slope field.
So let's think about what happens
when x is equal to a one,
whenever x is equal to y,
you're gonna get the
derivative equaling zero.
And you see that here,
when you're at four, four,
derivative equals zero.
When it's six, six,
At negative two, negative
two, derivative equals zero.
So that feels good, that this
is the right slope field.
And then we could pick
other arbitrary points.
Let's say when x is four, y is two,
then the derivative here
should be four minus two,
which is going to be two.
So when x is four, y is
two, we do indeed see
that the slope field is indicating a slope
that looks like two right over here.
And if it was the other way around,
when x is let's say, x is negative four
and y is negative two.
The negative four, negative two.
Well negative four minus negative two
is going to be negative two.
And you can see that right over here.
Negative four, negative two, you can see
the slope right over here.
It's a little harder to see,
looks like negative two.
So once again using even
just this first two comma two
coordinates we were able to
deduce this was the choice.
But it just continues to
confirm our original answer.